well two cover stars together for almost
three decades
how does it feel to have your love
celebrated so publicly with the knot
amazing
we were going to the airport today we're
like
look there we are on the cover of the
knot in the airport at lax and the store
so it was really fun
and it's such a fun moment to capture
you know 25 years of marriage
celebrating 25 years of not magazine
that was just a really great moment to
capture so it was fun a lot of fun and
our kids think it's great it's like oh
my god you know they sent us the box and
my kids are like opening it they see
their parents on the cover like this is
so exciting i feel like a common
question is what's the secret i'm gonna
dial that down a little bit more what
are the three non-negotiables for the
two of you in making this relationship
work gosh
we've been
what are the stumped
um
lying
[Laughter]
lack of trust well that would go with
lying i don't know i think the biggest
thing that we do is really try to spend
a lot of time together and you know we
often take our our own personal time and
invite the kids even though you know uh
we need our own personal time we still
have it with our kids so um but we're
both good with that so it works for us
exactly when you think about celebrating
25 years of marriage and being
celebrated by the magazine in this way
do you ever think about renewing your
vows or do you kind of believe in the
you did it one time it's good enough
don't need to you have zero interest in
removing and removing
it
i have
both exactly we don't want to review
them and we don't want to review them
um yeah it's been great it's worked out
you know we've actually talked about it
a couple of times we don't want to mess
with a good thing we've been super lucky
and why change you know
the energy that we have around us it's
very funny about numbers and synergy and
all that and
energy exactly what whatever we did work
and we don't want to mess with a good
thing so we're happy with that and we
will have plenty of other things to
celebrate in life so we're good
we just had our youngest daughter spot
mitzvah which honestly was one of my
favorite days of our lives it was such
an incredible event so we're good with
moments like that did paris's wedding
get you thinking about
oh farrah and alexia when pushing that
along maybe
oh yeah absolutely absolutely i know we
have we will have four weddings to
promote one day so and we're excited to
do that so uh yeah i don't think we need
to throw another party to renew our vows
um yeah
there'll be plenty of vows in the
extended umansky family to celebrate
yes we gotta talk ultimate girls trip
you show up on this experience hi girls
hi
the ramona coaster because she is all
over the place set the scene for me what
do you walk into what kind of chaos did
you find in this house
i definitely walked into some chaos i
was actually there working which
coincided which was awesome i went to go
have dinner with the girls and they
invited me to dinner and they had just
come off of some very chaotic moments
that i was that were shared with me um
thank god i didn't have to witness them
at my dinner my dinner was actually
relatively calm and cool and easy well
something did happen in the chat you
were just probably talking to one of the
guys you forgot probably hopefully i
spent some time with you guys and i was
expecting a little more drama and you
guys all seem to like each other you
should have seen what happened on the
yacht the other day
what happened on the yacht the other day
we both want to hear
do we have the repeat stories we're all
on such a good page oh my god we were
taught we
do we have to really talk about it right
now they were talking about
but yeah i i i got a chance to see kyle
one night and uh and be with her and it
was great
i had to do the walk of shame and just
put that out there you'll have to
witness that went down later
what a tease uh kyle you are the lone
beverly hills wolf on this show was that
the intention were you always gonna be
flying solo or were you supposed to have
a diamond holding buddy along for the
ride they always have me going solo
so um at first i was like why am i why
am i the only beverly hills girl going
but
um you know it's okay
they know i can handle myself decade
plus on reality television has proven
that at the least
unbelievable i heard courtesy of melissa
that you had to kind of tag team with
her to play ramona whisperer what
surprised you the most about going on
vacation with ramona singer i know about
the ramona coaster and you know i didn't
know what to expect it started pretty
much right out of the gate i mean we
haven't even landed and it started and
it was about the bedroom
who was in the best bedroom and i i
really thought she must be joking but it
wasn't a joke
no that is i mean she is if nothing but
consistent on that front um mo in the
premiere you let it slip that one of
your buddies used to date ramona singer
i know ramona she used to date a friend
of mine a long long time ago what had
you heard about this woman before she
kind of re-entered your orbit in the
housewife sense oh my god
that's right they used that part they
did i haven't seen it i wasn't i wasn't
aware um
he dated her before all of this went
down and uh it's been a long long time
and i i didn't really know her before
all of this so i can't really
um after experiencing these eight days
with ramona kyle would you do it again
or are you good never going on vacation
with ramona
oh no i you know i actually are ramona
yes she has her moments but
um
you know i also i've seen a lot
softer side of ramona and this very
sweet side of mona and she opened up a
lot about some things
towards the end of the trip which
explained a lot to me about ramona and
how she kind of operates and why she
does the things she does
you know you have to wait and see but
she is a lot of fun i will say yes she
offends people sometimes i i don't know
she's just very unfiltered and says
things that are not appropriate but she
also makes me laugh and i i forgive when
people make me laugh i can forgive
anything if you make me laugh and she
was really making me laugh and we were
always like the ones that were ready to
go and have fun all the time so people
were going to bed the first night we
were like what do you mean we're here to
have fun and so it's just the two of us
here's what's interesting about this
show that is so different you know than
how we do beverly hills and i'm this is
just not how we work is
the little hidden cameras and all the
corners of the room the ceilings we
don't work like that like you come you
know with the big cameras they put the
mic on you you know what you're getting
into i would be asleep in bed i was on
la time so all of a sudden a light would
go on above my bed at 7 00 a.m
which is 4 a.m l.a time and as soon as
that light would go on i would be like
and i'd hear
kyle are you ready to have a mic put on
and i was like are they kidding me i
haven't even washed my face or of course
my teeth what is this
and then i mean i would be going to
brush my teeth if a camera would
whizzing pass i'd be walking to brush my
teeth and they'd say can we get an
interview really fast and i was like
what are you talking about this is
madness like i've never seen for eight
days it was yes eight days chaotic
non-stop no breaks the fourth wall
getting broken all the time
um i think it's interesting that after
this all went down cynthia made the
decision not to return to the real
housewives of atlanta
i saw you recently kind of thinking
about the longevity of being a housewife
when will you know it's time to hand
your diamond over to someone else i
think when the bad outweighs the good i
will know it's time to
give up my diamond
um
i also think that um when you're not
having fun anymore
you know right now it's a lot you know
i'm juggling a lot but i have to say
that
nbc bravo peacock have been really good
to me and it's really fun to be able to
be doing the housewives and they're
allowing me the freedom to do the
ultimate girls trip and to do my
christmas movie
uh the houses of north pole it gave me
the time to do halloween and so the fact
that i'm able to juggle these things and
they're working with me around that um
and i'm still having fun
i love the women i work with contrary to
popular belief i know we argue but i i
really love all these women and
you know some of us obviously you know
closer than others but we have an
incredible cast and what i've learned in
doing the uh ultimate girls trip is that
not all the franchises are like that
they all feel like they're you know have
to watch their backs they don't trust
anybody you know our production doesn't
work like that i love our team
filming this show probably puts some
stuff into perspective of you of how
good maybe you have it compared to some
of the the other cities
oh for sure they were all some they
don't trust anybody they have to watch
the back i mean my girls from beverly
hills were checking on me when i was
there are you okay is everything good
like they're like sisters to me well
chances are some of your beverly hills
sisters will go on to do future
iterations of this show what's your
number one piece of advice for somebody
signing themselves up for the ultimate
girls trip in the future
really exhausting you better get all the
sleep in you can before you go because
you will not be having any down time i
mean there will not be a 30 minute break
let me tell you
i remember i was in the jacuzzi with
mona thinking we have 15 minutes oh okay
instead of going to change i'm just
gonna hop in the jacuzzi and we're
talking and all of a sudden they're
looking like oh yeah there's a camera
right in our face this is not actually a
50 minutes
there is
no
relaxation sleep for a week
but you will be entertained and you will
have some fun even though you'll be
exhausted and i know you are back to
work
on the main show right now i know you
can't really say anything about it but
can you at least calm the fears that
kathy will not be around people are very
worried that kathy is off the show uh
we're just gonna have to wait and find
out right now everything has been really
chaotic because we just started you know
paris has been planning her
wedding and now there's been
chaos everywhere with the wedding and
everything so we shall see okay that
didn't exactly calm me but i will wait
and see
um
mo i don't think i don't know that i've
ever heard you react to all the
attention you get
for being named hottest house husband
year after year after year how do you
feel about all that
you know i i honestly until i'm with you
here or until somebody comes up on the
street says you know i you know can i
have a photo or hey i'm a fan or i love
you or whatever i forget about it
when people say listen i i'll show them
oh i'd much rather it be me than pk
[Laughter]
but i do that there's no question and by
the way beating out harry hamlin you
know one of the sexiest men alive i'm
totally down with beating that one a man
out too so i do love that there's no
question about it all right you are you
accepted he's not ready to hang up that
title yeah you accept it but it doesn't
you don't let it define you i guess
we'll say thank you so much chris i need
you in my life
i need price yes all right well last
thing i want to ask you is when you got
married 25 years ago the life you live
now is not at all the life you are
living then between how successful just
you are in business and in family and
then becoming public figures how would
you say
that aspect has either complicated your
relationship or made you think
differently about how you treat your
relationship with the public weighing in
constantly i mean it's certainly not
what we expected we definitely face some
challenges because when you have
something great and people um see that
the happier you are the more they kind
of come after it so now it's like you
get more protective but it's definitely
made us stronger and you know we've
learned just to be even more protective
of our relationship and and appreciate
it and let me tell you if you can
survive this you can survive anything
[Music]
you